on va retourner retourner tout de suite
sur la place rouge de moscou avec vous
antoine un clairon on a vécu il y à
quelques instants cette cérémonie on a
vu le président russe vladimir poutine à
déposé une gerbe de fleurs près de là de
la flamme éternelle le président russe
qui s'est adressé à la nation
rappelons notamment l'importance est
spirituelle de ce jour de la victoire ou
tout à fait l'importance spirituel de
sûr de la victoire mais aussi cet esprit
de sacrifice de tout un peuple pour
pouvoir repousser repousser la menace la
menace nazie
loin de ses frontières je vous propose
d'écouter un morceau la fin de
l'allocution de vladimir poutine
ils ont combattu contre la mort pour la
vie et nous nous alignons sur leur
dignité
nous sommes réunis dans cet espoir dans
cet espoir dans ses aspirations
la responsabilité pour le présent et
pour l'avenir
nous savons et nous avons cette
assurance que nous sommes invités
invincible quand nous sommes ensemble
bonne fête bon jour de la victoire 1
pour 1 alors la suite de cette
allocution du président russe il n'y a
pas eu le traditionnel que traditionnel
défilé militaire sur la place rouge
coronavirus oblige mais à la place le
volet aérien a été conservé et 75
appareils 20 hélicoptères et 55 avions
militaires ont survolé la place rouge
avec les derniers appareils avec les
sens une traîne blanche rouge et bleu
aux couleurs
de la russie merci antoine état